i want to do a short segment on uh don
jr and maria bartoromo maria bartiromo
has become one of the biggest trump
family brown-nosers really in the world
but in particular on fox news and she
had a wild interview and i i'm not
making any speculative claims about don
jr's possible upper use i'm just not
going to do that on this show i'm just
going when i say he seems sped up i just
mean it seems like the videos of him
talking are sped up and donald trump jr
has now co-founded something called mxm
news i have no idea what it is it it's
very uninteresting to me but it's like
they've got rumble they've got truth
social now it's mxm news who can even
keep track of all these different things
uh and he showed up
and um
he is talking about
a panic about free speech and different
things these interviews just go nowhere
that the conservatives for a decade now
like these people are living in a bubble
they're not looking for a level playing
field maria they're looking for an
advantage they were always thrilled when
they have that advantage as though they
don't have enough advantages already
right they control the mainstream media
a trillion dollar enterprise they have
basically i love when they go on fox and
slam the mainstream media as if fox news
isn't part of the same corporate media
apparatus that they criticize all of big
tech another trillion dollar enterprise
they had all of social media again until
you came up with truth social and then
elon musk said hey how about some free
speech on twitter as well oh my god you
know the outrage and the panic and you
see it and that's why you see the leak
about the supreme court they need
something and they have nothing to
motivate their people now remember it
increa we still don't know who did the
supreme court leak but it's increasingly
looking like the best hypotheses are
that it was a right winger who did the
leak but that's just not convenient for
them american people are awake to it uh
they're starting to see what's real wow
they're awake it almost sounds like
they're woke oh what happened to the
algorithms the second the musk thing was
announced they saw the engagement that
they're getting on social and they
realized that they've been in a rigged
game for very long they see it and you
can no longer hide it maria and now the
crazy thing about this appearance other
than the fact that everything that he
says doesn't make any sense is he was so
hopped up on let's call it uh energy
that
he ranted for several minutes to the
point where maria bartoromo tried to
interrupt him and was isn't even able to
shouldn't disinformation until it wasn't
uh once they got what they wanted the
truth no longer mattered so now they can
say it's true they see the disaster that
joe's
biden's administration is so now they're
saying hey we'll throw him under the bus
let's let this be true now so check out
mxm news because those stories existed
but the powers that be made sure that
people never actually saw them and so we
have to make sure that people have
access to this kind of information and
so whether it's truth social whether
it's mxm news we are pushing back and
people are finally awake she has no
ability to actually take control of the
interview and this mxm news thing if you
check it out it's it says
mainstream news
without the mainstream bias
and it's available i guess it's an app
of some kind
that lets you cut through the noise
and
it's curated with no with no censorship
now i don't know how many people
understand that but
it's very hard to say something is
curated with no censorship i mean the
criticism that they have of the facebook
and twitter and etc algorithms are
it's being curated in a way we don't
like
they will often say
if twitter and facebook weren't censored
they would just be
chronological messages from everybody
you follow
the
algorithm that curates is a form of
censorship and they're promoting mxm
news as being
curated
but without any censorship it makes as
little sense as it sounds like it makes
monday memorial day we will be doing our
midterm membership bonanza we will be
blowing out memberships at a massive
discount everybody on my team is saying
david sir
please don't do it
don't do it it's too much of a discount
and i am telling them i'm doing it on
memorial day you'll all be sleeping and
i'll be giving out discounted
memberships if you want to be notified
of this great discount and you want to
sign up on monday memorial day just get
on our newsletter at davidpakman.com
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter i love this stuff cheese butter
is a delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter all the ingredients the
cheese the butter the seasonings are
sourced for the highest quality you can
really taste that this was made with
fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye
pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry and you'll
now get 20 percent off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below